pasan los días después de ese
aniversario Que recordaba ese primer año
de Invasión a escala máxima ordenada
desde Moscú por el presidente Vladimir
Putin y en la medida que pasan los días
se recuerdan también otros hechos que
hicieron entender la dimensión de esta
guerra a la que estaban sometidos los
ucranianos nos encontramos en la ciudad
de irpín en la cercanías de la capital
que en su momento era el máximo objetivo
de las fuerzas de Moscú y a mis espaldas
está ese que se convirtió en famoso
puente de la ciudad de irpín que fue
destruido en su momento por las fuerzas
ucranianas para evitar el avance de las
tropas de Moscú allí por ese puente en
las parte baja intentaban cruzar miles y
miles de personas que no solamente huían
de ir pin sino también de la ciudad de
bucha que era asediada y atacada
constantemente por las tropas de Moscú
aquel día el 6 de marzo un grupo de
personas habían ya pasado ese puente y
caminando por el lugar del frente donde
me encuentro y en ese momento se oyó una
gran explosión lo siguiente que vieron
los periodistas y los policías que
ayudaban a estas personas a subir fue
estos cuerpos tirados en la calle luego
se conoció que el nombre de una de ellas
era Tatiana una mujer una madre que
venía de la provincia de donex que había
escapado de la guerra en esa parte del
este del país en el don vast venía con
su hija y con su hijo y también allí
venía otro joven de otra provincia del
Don vas de Luján que también había huido
de la guerra en ese momento lo que
dijeron quienes investigaban crímenes de
lesa humanidad era que la comprobación
de que se estaban cometiendo crímenes
contra civiles algo que se había negado
ya desde Moscú especialmente lo había
negado el presidente Vladimir Putin Así
que esto marcó un antes y un después en
esta guerra luego ya se fueron
conociendo decenas y decenas de
atropellos cometidos por las fuerzas
rusas y en la actualidad hay más de
85.000 investigaciones de casos
similares en el país